today we're gonna be looking at some of
the top five video game WTF there are
way more than five out there but guess
what five is a nice round number and
it's the number of girlfriends I have
and by five I mean zero definitions I'm
not including things that are obvious
and intended and I'm not including
things that are fan-made but I really
wish I could and I'm also not including
things that are part of winning the game
number five is a co d mw2 WTF and yeah
it's a blow-up but not that kind this
kind in Assassin's Creed NPCs have been
found glitched out humping the walls at
amazing speeds I would be a lot more
weirded out if I wasn't so impressed by
their speed look at that I want that
world of warcraft is filled with WTS we
could make an entire countdown just
about them but let me show you my
favorite in dollar on there's a blood
elf who continuously strokes a red-hot
metal rod let's just take a moment of
silence if you jump on your Rhino and a
barrel at the same time you ride the
Rhino ride number one I love this
because of its subtlety it's in BioShock
after what appears to be a big explosion
take a look yeah that is why this is
number one so there you go to me those
are some of the top five WTF s and video
game but there are so many more if you'd
already seen every clip I talked about
today give this video a thumbs up to let
people know that you are a genius and if
you've seen others that weren't on this
list please put them in the comments I
want to see more of these things they
are awesome once you've done that be
sure to subscribe and stay saucy my
friends
hey hey are you still there okay awesome
listen to me there's this really cool
thing I found its called Facebook I
don't know it's kind of weird I don't
really get it but but we're there check
it out
there's a link in the description okay
okay bye
[Music]